Hola, me llamo Sabrina Wallace y mis padres formaron parte de la Fuerza Espacial en 1969.
Resulta que tiene un bonito cristal de forma similar.
Ahora, a mucha gente le gusta decir cosas que no necesariamente nos gustan para ayudar a la gente a entender cosas que son difíciles de entender porque, ya sabes, todo el mundo está ocupado ahora mismo preparándose para la guerra con drones, la guerra electromagnética con drones.
Lo hicimos en Irak y justo antes, y ya sabes, el país va a entrar en guerra de una forma u otra.
Ya sea que sea, ya sabes, nuestra propia gente o algo más, tenemos una grave deficiencia de aprendizaje en los Estados Unidos.
Ya sea que haya sido diseñado y diseñado o no.
Voy a dejar que otras personas hablen de eso.
Lo que voy a hacer hoy es mostrarte exactamente qué es lo que tienes que explicar a tus propios hijos para que podamos evitar la revolución del estilo de boca, estoy bastante seguro de que es lo que realmente están molestando.
Y lo haremos con la educación.
Así que voy a empezar.
No lo estamos.
Me llamo Sabrina Wallace.
Soy hijo de un Austin.
Y los miembros de mi familia participan en proyectos negros, proyectos de acceso especial.
Así que soy miembro de BAIER y mi abuelo es Bernard Heinrichs, y ese nombre es Sr.
Se casó con Helen Harding y Helen Harding está directamente relacionada con Pius Levi.
Mi padre era Steven Garland Davis.
Mi madre es Lynne Gene Scheer.
Ambos son Central Super secretos.
En 1969, trabajando en Project Silence, Soy un niño modificado gracias a la Experimentación para el aumento humano de la Fundación Menninger.
Ahora, todo lo que eso significa es que tengo cicatrices que la mayoría de la gente no tiene en la arquitectura de John von Neumann.
No es una interfaz entre cerebro y máquina.
Es masa corporal.
Eso es imposible.
Y suena: ¿Qué otra vez?
Estoy aguantando.
Así que aquí está la lista de bodas de mis padres.
Vale.
Aquí están los manifiestos de vuelo de Edgewood Arsenal para mi tío abuelo.
65/70 Army Chemical, Fort Dietrich.
¿A dónde?
Texas.
Nueva York, Corea del Norte.
Solo uno no es lo suficientemente bueno.
Eleanor Hall Sigue siendo para los tres.
Probablemente esté aquí y participé en los proyectos Mothman y en la construcción de vehículos para los Hombres de Negro.
Bien, la interfaz de las cicatrices de John von Neumann está justo aquí abajo.
Veo uno ahí.
Y por supuesto, ahora soy mayor, pero ese es tu corazón.
Vale, esta es la interfaz cuerpo-máquina con una base de datos clandestina llamada Next the Longer, que es IBM.
Así que en mi clase de alemán en el instituto, lo escribí mal.
Nick se cayó a la derecha.
Vale.
¿Por qué importa eso?
Porque si la gente dice cosas como estas, más vale que puedan mostrarte pruebas, pruebas viables, o de lo contrario no las escucharía.
Bien, aquí hay un poco más de documentación, y luego vamos a continuar y empezar con la discusión intelectual.
Vale.
Así que aquí están mi familia y Garland.
Mi abuelo, Garland Davis, un infante de marina de la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Fort Meade, NSA.
Mm hmm.
Y primero, se casó con Elizabeth Kraft.
Pero creo que algo con el ADN no funcionó.
Entonces se casó con mi madre.
Tía.
Vale.
Así que trabajabas para una empresa que eran mis padres y mi tío abuelo.
Oh, lo siento.
Se me olvidó una cosa.
Mi tío, mi tío abuelo está donde vivo.
Así que él es.
Siempre ha sido una de mis personas favoritas.
Es un hombre muy amable.
Oh, vamos.
Esta vez tenía todo en orden en la historia.
Vale.
Oh.
Tan sureño.
Así que tengo una historia totalmente diferente a la de mis padres.
Nunca me dijeron nada.
Nada.
Así que crecí y lo quería.
Y me dijeron que no existía nada excepto lo que se podía ver.
¿Y quería saber qué es todo este material electromagnético?
Crecí en los ochenta, en los noventa.
Nací en 1979, y si hablabas del aura, todo el mundo te arrinconaba y te exigía que te unieras a su grupo de lectores.
Y siempre estaba sentado ahí como: Te das cuenta de que es una parte del cuerpo.
Y yo digo: No, eres estúpido.
Tienes que tener una religión.
Nunca me di cuenta de lo que era.
No sabía por qué la gente se portaba de forma tan estúpida, ¿por qué mentirías sobre una parte del cuerpo?
Sin embargo, mis padres eran ardillas secretas.
Son cuatro niveles de aplicación de la ley por encima de todo lo que ven los civiles.
Y ellos son los ex.
La élite secreta.
¿Qué?
Es un servicio secreto de élite.
Y eso es prácticamente todo.
Una vez allí, será una policía secreta.
Ahora mismo, tienes que subir otro nivel.
Vale, ahora tengo que subir otro nivel.
Están hablando en serio.
Sí, puedo subir otro nivel.
Correcto.
Así que me puse manos a la obra para una empresa de Louisville, Kentucky, llamada High Speed Access.
Y fue entonces cuando me enviaron mis documentos para trabajar para que los vieran allí mismo.
Simplemente cogieron el sudor de su viejo adulto.
Esta es la vuelta al espacio para nosotros.
La parte trasera actual de este país.
Fui uno de los dos técnicos que conectaron el estado de Wisconsin desde el acceso telefónico a la banda ancha.
Así que lo tengo muy claro.
L-3 Harris o C 24, todas las diferentes formas en que manejamos todo tipo de inteligencia, el programa PRISM de la NSA, todo ello incluido los paquetes de gráficos de datos.
La ingeniería de redes no es lo mismo que instalar un módem de cable.
Tengo que trabajar con el técnico de la planta y el ingeniero de la planta.
Nadie alquila una planta ahí.
Y no había nadie contratado en ese puesto que no fuera el que tengo.
Sí, tenía 19 años.
Así que para el turismo internacional, mientras sigo aquí, la gente realmente no tiene nada que decirme porque estoy exactamente donde les digo que estoy.
Cuerpo completo.
Disculpe mi pie sucio.
Muy bien, entonces, hermana.
Vamos a ver.
Solicité servicios técnicos, red profesional de campus monitoreada por UW Whitewater, varios paquetes de software, que incluían mucho oro en la red Maps, HP vintage, vista abierta en breves interacciones con Snort.
Las operaciones del segundo turno incluyen el procesamiento de bases de datos con PeopleSoft, ocho enrutadores y conmutadores de codificación actualizados, el trabajo con Visio para crear un mapa de fibra de la formación iniciada en el campus.
Por lo que es simple, por supuesto, es prácticamente un estado completo como un pedacito.
Cuando fui al centro de operaciones de red de Louisville, o quería contratarme uno de esos consultores de redes de Omni Resources en Green Bay.
Conflictos de Trouble OS, problemas estudiantiles, conflictos de Shock West.
La empresa propietaria desarrolló el software, con la ayuda de Cisco Fixed Firewall, el asistente del programa del Departamento de Correcciones de Gales, Wisconsin, instaló e implementó un programa de rastreo interno del Departamento de Mantenimiento de Instalaciones de la Escuela para Niños Ethan Allen Desarrolle bases de datos y acceda y proporcione una dirección para la implementación de Oracle Solucionar problemas de red y escritorio dentro de los departamentos y un gran trabajo.
De octubre de 1999 al 22 de mayo, Charter Communications mantuvo una actualización y enseñó y solucionó problemas de la red ISP compuesta por tres Cisco, Kong Comm 2.1 y Bay Networks, tenía cinco racks instalados y los tenía en temporada.
La gerencia de Colin Cable, responsable del informe semanal y mensual, algunas pruebas de uso de ancho de banda y circuitos devolvieron módems de cable, problemas de garantía o redespliegue, área de responsabilidad de cobertura ligera para más de 12 000 clientes, instaló y mantuvo los servidores Cisco AC 5300 para siete grupos diferentes, supervisó el ancho de banda en los enrutadores Cisco 7200 configurados con actualizaciones para 9000 clientes y gestionó las relaciones entre el operador de cable y los técnicos en Plainfield, Illinois, al tiempo que capacitó al nuevo personal para los puestos técnicos y administrativos en enero de 2001.
Consulte la lista de software y eso es algo que su propio gobierno desactivó permanentemente en 2004 por estar deprimida por su propio gobierno.
Para cerrar la puerta a esto dicho, ¿sigues telepáticamente siguiendo proyectos?
Sabes, quizá no, pero a estas alturas ya va a ser divertido.
Así que, a partir de ahora, daremos un paseo por la realidad de hoy en 2022.
Y primero, vamos a aprender una pequeña lección del pasado.
En mi trabajo cuando trabajaba en UW Whitewater.
Tiene un enorme imán debajo de ella en un satélite fijo de órbita terrestre baja sobre ella.
Y durante los setenta, UW Whitewater tenía un montón de software para todas esas bases de datos clandestinas de Nick Furlong, IBM y demás.
Están bajo tierra.
Así que eso no es un tal vez, es una certeza.
Tiene que ver con la refrigeración más que nada.
Así que, de niño, crecí dibujando cosas como estas, probaban la interfaz cerebro-cerebro para detectar telepatía sintética.
Y hace tiempo que se le ha mentido a la gente acerca de esa parte electromagnética del cuerpo.
Y ahora estamos en crisis en nuestro país.
Esto es de 1993, y así es como funcionan los diseños de Bluetooth de Zigbee.
Así es como se ven.
Y así es exactamente como se procesan en las telecomunicaciones.
Y me voy a mostrar todo eso.
Pero quiero señalar que estaban haciendo pruebas en niños.
Sí, eso es lo que hace nuestro gobierno.
Los padres, mis padres, simplemente te entregan.
Ese es su trabajo.
Es un despliegue secreto para Synchronous.
No.
Lo siento, amigos.
No, vuelvo a eso de todos modos.
Así que este viaje para mí realmente comenzó ahí cuando era un niño, con problemas de acción con los escáneres, que en realidad consiste en tener el control de toda mi fisiología en lugar de escuchar a las personas que me rodean contarme una historia que me cuenta cómo evitar que pueda sentir mi propio cuerpo.
Y al crecer a partir de 1979, siempre me pareció extraño, inusual, pero no lo sabía.
No sabía que el núcleo de la vigilancia eran las biopelículas humanas.
Y una vez que lo hice, no estuvo bien.
Y mi familia me obligó a marcharme durante casi una década porque nunca se me permitió decir nada de Perch.
Chris: Son los años de otoño.
En 2019, me topé con una inglesa llamada ambulancia y, por teléfono, el tío de la ambulancia dijo: Llévala al helipuerto, llévala al albergue, llévala a la granja.
Ahora el gobierno me ha salvado perfectamente.
Era la primera vez que llamaba a una ambulancia.
No estaba preparado para eso.
Y entonces supe que los militares me estaban vigilando.
Y luego me enteré de un error cometido por nuestra Agencia de Inteligencia de Defensa a través de mis padres.
La verdad es que no.
Estoy aquí trabajando para Charter, pero siendo capaz de detectar radares y todas esas otras señales electromagnéticas.
Eso es natural.
El perro reacciona igual que yo.
No le decimos eso a la gente a menos que estés en la Infantería de Marina para conocer la situación.
Ahora, Stingray y Dirt Bikes usan la misma parte del cuerpo porque es electromagnética.
Y en 1953, el tío abuelo, se llevó a casa un montón de fotografías y drones electromagnéticos y en 1953 y nuevamente, mamá y papá en 1969 trabajando en el Proyecto Salus, que controla casi todos los estados moleculares que tenemos dentro y fuera del cuerpo humano.
Ahora, si nos fijamos en las células, nos dirán la logística y el movimiento y, básicamente, todo a nivel internacional por molécula.
Y tú dices: «Eso es imposible».
Esto se debe a que no conoces la nanoInternet de las cosas, la Internet industrial de las cosas y que muchos de estos sistemas de interfaz de máquinas existían en 1958.
Entonces, ¿por qué no se lo dijiste a la gente?
Quiero decir, Edgewood Arsenal.
Estamos haciendo pruebas con nuestros propios soldados.
Vietnam otra vez con mi abuelo.
Tenemos drones electromagnéticos en 1953.
¿Qué pasa?
Correcto.
Así que llegué a Virginia Occidental y lo raro con la ambulancia y luego continuó.
Más rarezas, vehículos que desaparecen.
Así que voy a las librerías y tienen esta pregunta.
Oh, estamos planificando para el condado.
Soy propietario de una casa, así que me dediqué a construir 60 cosas nuevas aquí mismo, en una ciudad de 200 personas.
Estaban ocupadas.
Parece raro.
Eh.
Eso me hizo empezar a investigar Six G lo pin y, al venir de la ingeniería de redes y la ciberseguridad, es uno de mis lugares favoritos porque me dedico a entornos matemáticos y tuvo que hacerlo porque tuve que subredes del back-end de las fuerzas espaciales en direcciones de cuatro puntos, que salieron a la venta en Florida el año pasado a partir de ahí.
Muy interesante.
Pero también lo descubrí.
De todos modos, cuando era ingeniero de redes y estudiaba para obtener un asociado de redes certificado por Cisco en su día, tenía que crear subredes en binario porque no teníamos suficientes direcciones IP.
Así que sí, leo matemáticas binomiales.
Antes era parte de mi trabajo.
Vale.
Y cuando se trata de ciberseguridad, este es el tipo de cosas de esta primera parte que están totalmente llenas de cosas aburridas, como las capas laterales e Internet y cosas así.
De nuevo, cuando tienes que subredes y tienes que aislar a tus clientes y estás en deuda con ciertos miles de personas y te culpan por 300 000 dólares por minuto de pérdida, se trata de comunicaciones chárter en ese momento.
Entonces tienes que saber lo que haces y no puedes equivocarte.
400 mil en un minuto.
Sí, es un tipo de presión a la que te enfrentas en un trabajo como ese.
Recuerde, solo hay dos personas en todo el estado que pueden manejar ese equipo.
Así que no puedes irte de vacaciones.
Básicamente tienes que ir al programa de niñeras.
Sí.
Así que seguridad de red, red de área personal baja en un 60%.
Y va a utilizar máquina a máquina, es decir, no habrá humanos involucrados en un vehículo ad hoc.
Fíjate, por ejemplo, aquí hay un delantero, aquí hay un dron.
Ahora, tengo un par de problemas.
En primer lugar, no puedes interrumpir ese dron.
La declaración 3000.09 del Pentágono afirma que fue hace más de 11 años y puede encontrarla en CSR.
Por ejemplo, el Pentágono dijo en mayo de este año 2022 que creo que nuestros comandantes sobre el terreno deben poder leer el aprendizaje automático.
Bueno, está claro que el comandante, el esposo, especialmente el comandante, no asistió al Simposio de Inteligencia Artificial el 10 de septiembre de 2020.
Si el comandante lo hubiera hecho, sabría que no se trata de un sistema nervioso digital de principio a fin sin humanos involucrados, cito, en el Proyecto Selous.
¿Qué aprendimos sobre la entrega del producto?
Dales el código.
La plataforma Salus se utiliza para NORTHCOM con actualizaciones para los proveedores.
Lo que cambia las reglas del juego son los nuevos prototipos neuronales que se están desarrollando y están disponibles aquí.
¿Y qué?
Para empezar, el nuevo prototipo neuronal Synchro, el G Joint Artificial Intelligence.
Qué es Fuzing es una organización de fuzing que se centra en hacer llegar los productos a las personas que realmente los utilizan.
Luego discutieron si serían servicios de red híbridos o digitalizados de Amazon, y Microsoft y Amazon dijeron: o me dejarían tener un contrato con el gobierno.
Vale.
Luego se puso más raro para mí.
Y mientras escucho, dijeron servicios de etiquetado de datos.
Y yo digo: Esa es una curación masiva de datos de bases de datos.
Y estoy pensando en qué proveedor, clientes y yo escribimos: Este es el Departamento de Defensa.
Para eso puedes ir aquí al principio y dice que el equipo de Jake, me refiero a la Comisión Conjunta de Inteligencia Artificial, su función es crear la IA.
real y todo el mundo puede y debe implementar la inteligencia artificial en todo lo que hace.
Clientes de todo el Departamento de Defensa.
¿Cuáles son tus clientes?
Mira esto.
Así que Contrasting Tools está bajo el paraguas de Tradewinds y el proyecto Maven y cito los conductos calientes que utilizan sensores inteligentes, Biosensors Wireless Working Group 82.1 5.5 Wireless Sensor Networks Specialized Working Group para los estándares internacionales de electrónica e ingeniería disculpe, electrónica e ingeniería eléctrica.
Y Project Maven usa a Pathfinder y a mí para verte caminar y pensar dentro de tu casa en tiempo real.
Y vamos a citar el proyecto MQ nine Tethered to ground.
Esa es la directiva 3000.09 del Departamento de Defensa, que una vez más afirma que por eso el comandante estaba de mal humor porque decía: no podemos oír estas máquinas, no podemos decodificarlas por su naturaleza y no podemos transmitir una señal.
Y cito aquí en la puerta, necesitamos que el sistema de la Fuerza Aérea de IBM sea más coherente con todo lo demás.
Vamos a crear un sistema nervioso digital de principio a fin.
Tenemos que rehacer en el Departamento de Defensa la forma de conectar todas las plataformas de IBM.
¿Qué controlan?
Plataformas para lesbianas, vehículos autónomos.
Te refieres a drones autónomos, tanques, Strykers normales, todo tipo de cosas.
Aviones, compruébalo.
¿Qué hay de cualquier otra cosa?
Absolutamente.
El Internet industrial de las cosas es de esos mil millones que tienen vehículos autónomos y todo es aire aliado.
Pero si pensabas que solo era por la parte inteligente, deberías buscar en la ingeniería RF una nueva forma de salvar el día llamada Green Road.
No es una nueva fibra especializada a lo largo de la interestatal.
Cuando se le preguntó si podría usar un poco de luz para mover la ladera montañosa donde se encuentran las monarcas y el acceso especial al Instituto Nacional de Ciencia y Tecnología de Curtis para el gobierno, paga a la gente, no es broma, proyectos negros, recuerden que realmente no pago 45 mil dólares por un asiento de inodoro entero.
No, no lo hacen.
Pero, ¿sabes qué?
Se encargan de los lirios asquerosos.
Para que las personas tengan una pila como esta, tienen que introducir cinco códigos para ocultar adónde va todo el dinero y la asignación de recursos, la logística y el envío, y luego la reasignación de personas de proyectos de acceso especial y, luego, la reasignación de quien esté a cargo de protegerlas, rastrearlas, rastrearlas o el Departamento de Defensa a una lista para modificar proyectos de acceso especial.
Se sale de control y todo es de código abierto y puedes leerlo y buscarlo en Google.
Así que ese es nuestro problema aquí.
Entonces, ¿quieres explicarme qué son estos biosensores y de qué estás hablando?
Un dron MQ Nine Reaper.
Está ligado a mi ADN.
¿Qué está pasando?
Y, por cierto, ¿quiénes son tus clientes?
En realidad.
Ciberseguridad.
Sí.
Primer simposio de Inteligencia Artificial.
Les dijeron que todos los humanos están fuera del camino, así que debo decir que uno al sistema nervioso digital de extremo a extremo para estas plataformas conectadas con los humanos fuera del proceso y al razonamiento, permitir al gerente actual utilizar directamente las células de crédito de la ciencia de datos y.
Desde que era niño.
Entrevistas sobre la interfaz de la máquina.
Bases de datos cuánticas.
Correlación de gerentes.
Ahora, ¿por qué harían eso?
Así que la nueva red de área personal 60 utilizará tu cuerpo para enrutar los datos.
Y antes de que pienses: Oh, no, nos dirían que se hizo en 2005.
Eso es lo que es la red de sensores inalámbricos.
Los biosensores son básicamente permanentes y de por vida desde 2005 y desde 2005 con Zigbee y Bluetooth, que es de lo que me quejé antes cuando lo envié, era solo un niño.
¿Por qué Zigbee, Bluetooth y estos biosensores se ven exactamente así?
Porque así es como funciona.
Los estándares internacionales de electrónica e ingeniería eléctrica utilizan una red de área corporal amplia y 82.1 5.6 Los estándares electrónicos para el grupo de trabajo inalámbrico Wide Body Area Network 82.1 5.6.
Y estos son los cuatro círculos de su redacción técnica sobre lo que son capaces de hacer a través del cuerpo.
Y como siempre, ya sabes, no deberíamos tener más parapléjicos y todo eso.
Pueden hacer que tus manos se muevan.
Controlan la densidad del tejido muscular.
Te pueden hacer hablar.
Lo pueden hacer.
Y lo hacen ahora mismo.
Supervisan todas estas cosas de forma inalámbrica.
¿Cómo es eso posible?
¿Si tu cuerpo necesita un dispositivo portátil o está usando tu router o está usando tu router o está usando otra cosa?
Quería saberlo, así que lo averigüé.
Con la nueva ciberseguridad aquí con el Stryker y ella tiene que ser máquina a máquina, tal y como se dijo en el simposio del DIA de.
El problema es que la autonomía es un N9 vacío atado a tu ADN y que el ADN genera una parte electromagnética del cuerpo.
Y nadie sabe nada de eso.
Lo llaman aura, lo llaman todo tipo de cosas.
Oh, son ovnis.
No lo sabemos.
Sí, lo tenemos.
Skunk funciona, Raytheon.
Te acabo de mostrar la foto.
La gente de los drones puede trabajar durante más de 40 años y cobrar de verdad, de verdad.
Bien.
Te mantenemos en la oscuridad.
Ciberseguridad, militar, ya sabes, seguridad nacional.
Oh, son UFO Skunkworks, Raytheon, Lockheed.
Todo el mundo lo sabe.
Son vendedores.
Entonces, ¿qué es todo eso de los registros psíquicos?
Científicos.
Son inherentes al tejido humano.
Así que había un libro que solía hacer que mis alumnos leyeran cuando enseñaba sobre esto cuando era niño.
Aquí está en 1996.
Este libro fue escrito.
Se llama Psicología Integral.
Y en su interior encontrarás lo que acabo de decir sobre la telepatía, la empatía, la precognición, todo eso.
Se asigna a ciertas áreas del cerebro.
Entonces, ¿esas redes de sensores se han reducido a nanoescala?
Luego lo ponen en un software propietario cuando tienen que escribir para Zigbee y Bluetooth para esos biosensores permanentes de por vida y, ya sabes, 2.1, 5.4, están permanentemente adheridos a tu cuerpo, donde.
Desde las sincronizaciones por radiofrecuencia.
Hay dos de ellos.
Extraerán toda la energía electromagnética, incluida la potenciación de los minerales, de tu torrente sanguíneo bioquímico y la transducirán porque tu campo electromagnético que pensabas que no tenía valor no existía y todos se burlaban de ti.
De hecho, transduce cualquier cosa electromagnéticamente.
Ahora usamos radio sintética.
Se trata de una radio definida por software.
Telepatía sintética, solo para agitar la piel.
Un poco transducido electromagnéticamente hacia adentro y hacia afuera, usando partes de tu propio cuerpo.
Entonces, ¿cómo crees que están?
¿Datos informáticos?
De la misma manera.
Los biosensores son imanes literales.
Se fijan y se ajustan con el voltaje.
Cómo hacer Wireless Working Group ADA 2.15.5.
Y esa es tu red de área personal.
También son su red de área personal.
En mi época, como puede ver aquí, el Maupin de seis G puede o no tener una red de área corporal con fines de enrutamiento de seguridad.
Están enviando sus datos a través de sus tejidos y cito un intercambio de información digital que utiliza la conductividad eléctrica del cuerpo humano como una red de datos (red de área corporal).
Entonces, ¿por qué no necesitamos un chip cerebral?
Porque llevas 6000 años sin cables.
La medicina china, los meridianos, los chakras, son puntos nodales del cuerpo, telemetría electroelectromagnética.
Así que los biosensores permanentes se extendieron a todo el mundo aquí arriba en 82.1 y 5.4, y tuvieron que ser permanentes para Zigbee y Bluetooth, y eso es lo que los proporciona.
Y luego, el medidor de grupo de trabajo inalámbrico 2.1, 5.5 se encarga de todos los diferentes tipos de redes, luego recopila ciertos sensores solo de ciertos cuerpos, abre el camino más corto, primero los protocolos de enrutamiento o por motivos de seguridad.
Pero además, cuando los crean con Zigbee y Bluetooth, tienen que seleccionar el tipo de tejido muscular.
Desde 2008, tienen que seleccionar el calor para que no se huela a muerte.
Y así estuvieron trabajando en ello hasta 2011, en 2013.
Y ahora tienen unos 13 protocolos de enrutamiento diferentes, pero solo unos tres de ellos están diseñados para protegerlo de la información en la que incurre al enrutar los datos a través del cuerpo, que extrae minerales de los glóbulos rojos para hacerlo.
Ahora, es un aviso de nivel cero muy pequeño hasta que demasiadas empresas utilizan esas estadísticas matemáticamente al mismo tiempo.
Y esto es lo que parece.
Así que justo aquí, en nuestro pequeño ejemplo, es posible que también desee observar que estos dos son de seis, cada uno tiene cinco nodos que sobresalen de ellos, que se han etiquetado aquí mismo y uno, dos, tres, cuatro, cinco.
Así que por cada pequeño punto, hay cinco más y todos son accesibles electromagnéticamente a través de la nube comercialmente con Zigbee y Bluetooth, que de nuevo son, ya sabes, 2.1, 5.4, porque si no lo fueran, no podrían vender Zigbee y Bluetooth en la pared.
No podrían haber usado la Alexa de esa manera.
Todas estas cosas diferentes se comunican con estas redes de sensores, y todas están impulsadas por bases de datos de inteligencia artificial y todas están interconectadas.
Así que si eres inalámbrico y estás en el mismo grupo de trabajo inalámbrico que tu teléfono, que en realidad es, ya sabes, 2.1.
Por lo tanto, en una amplia red de área personal, enrutan sus datos a través de usted.
Desde 2005, puedo crear una aplicación para ella y luego puedo jugar contigo de esta manera porque están accesibles desde 2005.
¿Crees que la gente no ha tenido tiempo suficiente para comprar telepatía sintética, dispositivos portátiles?
Está todo escrito.
Y si no sabías que escribir una aplicación no es difícil y los GitHub la diseñaron con algo llamado lenguaje de consulta estructurado, oye, qué es lo que te invita a salir al backend de Microsoft, Apache y WordPress y preguntarte a todos: Hola, este es el Hadoop del estilo.
Así que estas personas en los noventa antes de que esto se lanzara en 2005, y con estas personas me refiero a la ardilla secreta de mis padres, la policía secreta, todo esto de nuevo, para quién otra vez, la Fuerza Espacial desde 1969, señales, inteligencia, etc.
De acuerdo, tienen algo llamado interfaz cerebro-cerebro, una telepatía sintética y es impulsada por la frecuencia de igual a igual.
Sí.
Y se ponen un casco en su escritorio y pueden recorrer el tejido humano.
Una vez más, estas cosas se monitorean en tiempo real.
Díganos si eso no fue lo suficientemente malo.
También lo muestran en todas las bases de datos de colecciones que ve en la lista aquí.
Así que la televisión, todos tus sentidos, esas cosas, el radar, el Doppler y, luego, las cajas sucias vuelan por encima de tu cabeza y se comunican con el software Stingray, que está escrito para los departamentos del alguacil individuales, según el tipo de bases de datos a las que quieran suscribirse.
Así que lo que queda es que hay tres cuerpos caminando por la carretera.
Hay dos cuerpos en una casa.
Estos cuerpos ahora están siendo utilizados por el mismo conductor porque resulta que sus cuerpos tienen la mejor seguridad en una máquina.
La máquina solo usa esos criterios y aparecen en la lista si quieres leer la máquina y aprender a ver el pedido.
Y luego, la clave para separar cuántas veces golpean el nodo, cuánto tiempo esperan con un retraso de 0,06 segundos.
Y lo mismo ocurre con la ciberseguridad para todo.
Hola.
Adiós.
Intermitente.
Espera, quédate.
Y si sabe algo sobre el hackeo de datos con paquetes de verdad y no solo las cosas de la nube empresarial definidas por software, es decir, y principalmente utilizando software, es decir, como el lado del hardware, separan todo el paquete hasta la capa física de direcciones Mac de su cuerpo.
Ese es el problema en el que estamos.
Por eso estamos al límite.
Están conectados a su médula ósea.
Y la forma en que Cisco McCann alimenta todo lo que los rodea en la red inteligente es cuando caminas, bailas y te mueves.
Y esa es otra parte sobre la que puede leer en ocho, 2.1, 5.5 y en las redes de área corporal ancha 802.15.6.
De nuevo, el problema con el que nos topamos es que cuando hay tres cuerpos caminando por la carretera, estos dos están emitiendo toneladas de señales que indican que cada nodo tiene cinco más.
Ahora, todos estos sensores se están volviendo locos.
Esta persona aquí, la máquina selecciona a esta persona aquí, el ADN, tu ADN, tu cuerpo.
Eso es lo que crea la señal segura de que el dron está propagando tu ADN.
Y así es exactamente como funciona.
Así que para evitar que este dron dispare cualquier cosa, tienes que impedir que tu ADN se propague.
¿Por qué harían eso?
Así que por última vez.
Si tienes mala suerte y alguien es alcanzado con un arma biológica.
Se trata de una transducción eléctrica a través del grupo de trabajo inalámbrico abierto de redes de área corporal amplia.
Así que no importa en qué creas.
Y nunca lo hizo.
Hicieron todo eso aquí mismo.
Los dos erais psíquicos.
Y luego, cuando transducen humanos y realizan pruebas reales, que consisten en ingeniería de tejidos inalámbrica y control piezoeléctrico total inalámbrico, mitigación neuronal para la modulación del comportamiento.
Tenemos daño cerebral.
Te refieres a áreas muy sutiles de tu cerebro a nanoescala para mantener tu comportamiento bajo control.
Luego lo enviamos a la gente y le decimos que la terapia cognitivo-conductual lo ayudará en Cougar Needs Artificial Intelligence Programing.
Sabemos que si lo dices una y otra vez, lo vas a hacer.
Entonces, ¿por qué no arreglarían su entorno epigenético?
Porque eso no les interesa.
O le habrían contado estas cosas a la gente hace mucho tiempo.
Estudiaban el transporte y ponían a prueba a las personas para comprobar sus habilidades científicas en bioinformática y genómica.
Una vez que su cuerpo ya no puede transducir estas señales electromagnéticas, esto es antinatural, hay demasiada energía en el torrente sanguíneo, en los huesos y en el sistema vascular.
Con el tiempo, debilita las venas, las arterias y la piel y, entonces, te metes en problemas.
¿Así que finges perderte en el bosque?
¿Pasaste a la clandestinidad?
Estoy bromeando.
Así que esto es lo que hicieron.
Nadie ha dicho la verdad.
Stingray y las fuerzas del orden se pusieron manos a la obra en 1972.
Así que el jefe de policía me usó con mi cerebro o, perdona, con la interfaz del cuerpo de mi máquina en ese momento, porque todavía tenían que tener una mesa de estudio con nanolípidos o hidrogel para poder revisarla y mostrarla en un monitor.
Eso es lo que son todos esos guardias.
Así que ahora todo el mundo está tranquilo desde 2005 y está disponible comercialmente.
Y una vez más, el nuevo estándar de ciberseguridad es una red de área corporal amplia que puede estar involucrada o no en una red de área personal que puede o no involucrar su iPad y todo lo demás.
La ciberseguridad está aquí mismo, en febrero de 2022, para la identificación digital abierta seis veces.
el enrutamiento y las ideas digitales creadas con tu teléfono.
Eso es correcto.
¿Frecuencia y residencia de tu qué?
Su ADN generado de forma electromagnética es una parte del cuerpo accesible de forma inalámbrica desde 2005 comercialmente.
Nunca te avisan de que tu médico no lo admitirá.
Vas a aprender.
Hablaremos de ello.
Y si lo intentas.
Pero me burlo de ti.
¿Por qué?
¿No quieres el control total y los humanos y tenerlos en los controles remotos para que hagan lo que quieras?
Sin libre albedrío, sin capacidad de pensar.
Ya te lo he dicho.
Mitigación neuronal con sutil.
¿Qué otra vez?
Modificación de la conducta.
Una vez más.
Signos vitales, respiración.
Fácil.
Audífono con monitor de monitorización ACG de glucosa.
¿Cuáles son los usos no médicos de lo que se introduce en el hueso?
Porque cuando lo hacen, tus glóbulos rojos tienen que funcionar de manera correcta y extraerán magnéticamente esos minerales que tengo en mis hombros, de tu torrente sanguíneo.
Bueno, transmisión de datos de vídeo, transferencia de archivos deportivos, 3D, vídeo, cosas olvidadas, monitor.
Y luego, una vez más, se te permitirá hacer tres cosas: aplicaciones de entretenimiento, relaciones públicas y juegos y redes sociales.
Empezando a ver cómo el metaverso electroceutica el Internet de las cosas, el Internet de los cuerpos, el Internet cibernético de las cosas.
Ahí, aquí, todo está unido dentro de tu cerebro.
Así que cuando traté de contarle a la gente cómo soy gracias a los proyectos de sangre, tienes que entender esta parte del cuerpo y, si no empiezas a trabajar con ella, empiezas a descubrirla.
Esto es una guerra de aviones no tripulados.
Vas a esperar, no a nadie.
Así que lo que tienes que hacer es entender que lo único que tienes ahora mismo es primero la fisiología, es decir, admitir que es la parte del cuerpo.
Lo atacan para esclavizar totalmente a los humanos y lo tienen.
Es increíble que todo se haga en el departamento de policía, en los departamentos del alguacil.
Como he dicho, terminaron en 1972, y podían hablar entre sí con telepatía sintética y con un montón de niños pequeños.
Y luego, cuando éramos adolescentes, llegó el resto con el 2013, cuando lanzaron la interfaz de chip cerebral.
Profesionalmente, la gente aún no lo sabe.
Siguen pensando que necesitas un chip real en tu cerebro.
No lo haces.
Simplemente vaya a comprar una nanoantena con la frecuencia adecuada para la red de área corporal amplia.
Son como cien dólares y luego compras un dispositivo portátil generador de telepatía sintética de 200 dólares que se introduce en los nervios craneales con mucha sutileza y te permite escuchar todas las señales que te rodean y que se proyectan en estas redes.
Estas redes están conectadas a todo lo que hay en el Internet de las cosas, el Internet industrial de las cosas, el cibernano Internet de los cuerpos, y se burlan de los cuerpos de Internet para ellos.
Como si no conocieras la especificidad, entonces tienes que hacerlo porque luego dijeron: Oh, pero solo es en los hospitales.
Y yo digo: No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Es una tontería si, quiero decir, es un diseño de ingeniero.
¿Por qué lo dejarías solo en el hospital?
Quiero decir, ni siquiera funcionaría de esa manera.
Es completamente inalámbrico, satelital, incluido.
Entonces, ese dron elige tu ADN porque ese MQ nueve está atado a ti.
Recuerda que acabo de señalar esto y me voy a decir MQ Nine.
Diez de septiembre de 2020.
Inteligencia artificial Pentagon MQ nine atado a tierra Project Maven Project Pathfinder con detección de objetos.
Eso es correcto.
En un área del cuerpo cognitivo, las redes se están volviendo muy confusas porque usan algo llamado red adversaria y te atacan.
Porque están vigilando.
Piensas con esos comentarios cognitivos para ver el radar cognitivo que te observa pensar en tiempo real.
Y aparece con un disfraz pequeñito y hacen clic en un botón.
Sufrieron un ataque al corazón y un derrame cerebral o cualquier cosa que quieran, cualquier molécula, cualquier estado al que nos enfrentemos, todo está a su disposición desde 2005.
Oh, como mínimo.
Mis padres se sometieron a este procedimiento, así que es en 1969.
Todas las moléculas del planeta, en todas partes.
Entonces, ¿cómo llegamos aquí?
¿Cómo se puso todo esto en su lugar?
Sin responsabilidad mental, sin mendacidad, nada.
Dejamos que se salgan con la suya primero.
Se estaban electrocutando sutilmente.
Muchas personas contrajeron fibromialgia, pero nadie lo sabía.
Dije que un tumor es que tienes un tumor, pero no podemos encontrarlo físicamente.
Es que tu cerebro actúa como si fuera una seudoconvulsión.
Así que, caramba, no sabemos por qué tienes tantos ataques entonces.
El lupus, la enfermedad de Lou Gehrig, es una enfermedad autoinmune que el 80% del sistema inmunitario se encuentra en esa parte invisible del cuerpo del 40 al 60% del sistema endocrino.
Esa es la razón por la que todas las hormonas nunca pueden controlarse.
Sigues alterando la transducción eléctrica de la estructura celular básica de tu órgano más grande.
Vamos, gente.
Y luego no lo hacen.
Enfermedades.
Oh, no sé qué es eso.
Lo hacen.
La Organización Mundial de la Salud admitió que el cáncer no es mi historia para contar, por lo que la dejo abierta.
Así que mucha gente ya lo descubrió con el cáncer.
Dicen: «Espera, estoy harto de que ahora quieras que me someta a quimioterapia».
¿Como qué?
Y sí, entonces no el Sr.
Endo, pero ahora estamos muy involucrados en el síndrome de muerte súbita de adultos.
Caramba, no sabemos por qué.
Y cuando se mueven demasiado y se les transduce oxígeno en los glóbulos rojos, resulta que demasiado es demasiado radar de los servicios de envío de Amazon.
Las empresas normales prestan demasiada atención a la seguridad.
Tal vez solo sea una empresa normal que está dragando geología o la cima de un conjunto rocoso o lo que sea, ahora lo está extrayendo de tu cuerpo para escanear la zona.
Una vez más, es solo una parte de un grupo de trabajo sobre sensores inalámbricos formado por ATO, 2.1, 5.5 y point four.
Pero ahora usa tu cuerpo porque estás en, ya sabes, 2.1, 5.6.
Y para nuestros propósitos, para esto, en lugar del Stryker, es un satélite.
Necesita tu cuerpo en ocho o 2.1, 5.6.
Se trata de sensores de vida útil permanente disponibles en el mercado desde 2005.
Y el Departamento de Defensa vende a través de la base de datos el acceso para usted utilizando nuestro mismo censo y Doppler y calefacción y luz y dónde vive y con quién habla.
Por eso, la única razón que me llevó hasta aquí fue cuando me di cuenta de que mi condado, quienquiera que sea cerca del que viva, mi pequeño pueblo de 200 habitantes, está mirando a través de mi torrente sanguíneo.
Sigue abierta y eso me ha asustado.
Seguí el enlace e hice la lectura en todo el país y, nuevamente, estamos en febrero de 2022 para lo digital.
Salté una geocerca atrapando a la gente para que no pudieran salir de su geocerca.
Pero nadie te dijo que eras inalámbrico porque no quieren darte el mando a distancia de tu propio cuerpo.
Entonces, ¿qué vas a hacer al respecto cuando el radar llegue a ti y ella esté lista con su ADN para acabar contigo?
Porque esa es la declaración sobre armas autónomas letales que seguí leyendo en ese libro de texto universitario.
Sí.
Así que no puedes oírlo, ¿verdad?
Tu cuerpo no lo oirá entrar, ya sea un dron o un transducto.
Sin embargo, eso es una luz en mi canal, An Odyssey.
Está lleno de supervivientes de la guerra electromagnética, personas como yo con las que se probó este material y luego se implementó a escala de gobernanza industrial para la Agencia de Inteligencia de Defensa, la NRO o quien sea.
Lo que tenemos que entender ahora es que se te acaba el tiempo porque van a ir a la guerra.
Y llevan haciendo esto desde 2005.
Y de nuevo, mi familia estuvo aquí en 1969.
Así que aquí en mi canal, enseño prácticas de biopelícula, enseño ataque y defensa.
La defensiva es genial porque entonces te abres dentro de tu propio campo y aprendes a escuchar y respirar realmente.
Pero la práctica ofensiva del biofilm llegó la semana pasada, y al menos te sugiero que la observes antes de probarla y antes de hacer cualquier cosa, vuelvas a familiarizarte con tu cuerpo y corrijas todas las cosas que te enseñaron mal para que puedan acceder a ti a distancia y quitarte el sistema inmunitario, porque lo que va a pasar son las cargas plasmáticas.
Y si ves que 2030 habla de esto, esas cargas de plasma.
Sí, es verdad.
Parte electromagnética del cuerpo, la vas a sentir de cualquier manera.
Pero si tienes conocimientos con antelación, no vas a tener miedo y estarás mejor preparado para observar tu entorno topológicamente epigenéticamente y entender realmente a las personas que son cómplices de todo esto que es realmente malo.
Le dirán que sus biopelículas comienzan de manera real o no hablarán de ello.
Y luego, si están involucrados en aproximadamente dos tercios, son los propósitos de este país.
Se limitarán a fingir que no importa y que, oh, no me puede afectar.
Creo que este es el centro de la revolución.
Están atacando a nuestro país porque nuestros jóvenes ponen en peligro biológico estas cosas y saben lo fácil que es comprar esos 400 dólares y tener telepatía y afectar a la gente de Hollywood.
Lo han estado haciendo durante mucho tiempo.
Bueno, ahora van un paso más allá con las tendencias de ingeniería de tejidos, la magnificación.
Y le dije a la gente que van a convertir la parte inferior de tu brazo en pescado.
Pero luego dicen: Oh, no estamos juntos.
Y ahora está aquí.
Hay médicos que se ofrecen a cambiar el ADN de las personas y cambiarlas a estados animales, etc.
Sí, sabemos que eso es en lo que interviene todos los días.
Vale, entonces, primer paso, tienes que ser honesto acerca de tu fisiología.
Tienes una parte invisible del cuerpo y todos lo saben excepto tú.
Eso es un problema.
¿Por qué?
Porque lo importante es tu cuerpo.
Todo el cuerpo al instante.
Ahora proyecta ese campo.
Steamer Sports.
Eso estaba completo.
Echemos un vistazo al sesgo que en realidad parece energía electromagnética, ¿no?
Oyes venir los drones.
Lo vas a sentir.
Tu cuerpo lo hace de forma natural.
Algore parece para los pájaros.
Todo eso señala líneas clave.
Los militares los han estado usando durante mucho tiempo.
¿Por qué no lo sabías?
¿Por qué no se te permite saberlo?
Primer paso Es una parte de tu cuerpo.
Segundo paso: reconciliarse con Dios.
Oración por las personas que son como uno.
Jesús.
Vale, bueno, lo que quieras.
Fisiología.
En primer lugar.
Es una parte del cuerpo y ponte en paz con Dios.
Oración para que las personas representen todas las formas de amor.
Luego practica religiones, lo que sea.
Vale, los avisos están separados.
Que cualquier cosa en la que creas es el deber que te ama.
Saber que hay algo más grande que tú.
Eso es privado.
Eso es personal.
Tu alma, un ser soberano en tu piel.
Súper.
Vale.
Así que si alguien tuviera unos imanes con ajuste de voltaje, los entregara a las fuerzas del orden y a la vigilancia secreta y no a los médicos, no a nada.
¿Durante cuántos años?
Entonces, de repente, después de que el proyecto dijera: Escucha, digo: Oh, Dios mío, estamos metidos en muchos problemas.
Gatos, perros y peces de colores.
Y fue entonces cuando me puse muy bocazas este año, en abril.
Y dije: «La zorra de las burbujas, aquí están tus venas y arterias».
Están bien.
Muy bien ahora.
Es decir, no se esfuerzan mucho.
Pero tanto esfuerzo.
Esto es.
Observe con atención y luego vaya a ver cómo se ve la biosfera cuando todo lo espera.
Retorcido.
Condenado.
No vas a apretar el gatillo.
Tendrás mucha suerte si puedes llegar a mi puerta.
Y por cierto, precognición, de nuevo, en el libro que te mostré, las arañas comen con ella.
Entonces, ¿por qué sigues fingiendo que no estás en su Agencia de Inteligencia de Defensa?
Bases de datos del Pentágono con todos los sueños que tienes y que tu precognición también es observada en tu tejido.
Por eso las arañas comen con él.
Lo mismo ocurre con Algore.
Todo es natural y todo el mundo siempre dice: Oh, me encanta estar en la naturaleza.
¿Por qué todos estos cables y esas cosas?
Y muy pronto se van a ir.
Y la mayoría de la gente no sabía que teníamos todo este plasma atómico de matorral y todo lo demás.
Lo teníamos en el siglo XIX y nos lo quitaron durante 150 años para venderte tu sistema inmunológico y encerrarte.
Ahora lo han hecho, no tenemos su biocombustible y la próxima guerra electromagnética.
No sobrevivirás.
Es así de sencillo.
Así que ahora tienes posibilidades y no tienes mucho tiempo.
1953.
¿Qué crees que tienen ahora?
Tú.
Y luego.